this is a big moment your life I know
that one of your all-time favorite
people is the rock yeah it goes without
explanation you love the rock the rock
tweeted at you yes he did we put that up
this is pretty big stuff you talk about
him in your act
thanks Funches for calling me the
Beyonce for boys which is in your head
very funny line in your act and maybe
you are a rock bottom dead what's he
talking about there I think that means
he wants to have sex with me and I know
what positions that's great that he hide
it I mean he saw it he must have seen it
on your on your special right he heard
about it because when I trip with you
that was a very funny part of your act
you've a tremendous act and that you
would talk about your fantasy of of the
rock and everyone's fantasy yeah he is
perfect he's perfect
he doesn't matter what your sexuality is
doesn't matter you know when the rocks
involved were all interested yeah he's
basically just a statue of a man like me
who could hate that he has a production
company with his ex-wife I don't have to
say no more that's kind of magical that
he can pull that off
yes amazed I wouldn't want to want work
with my ex-wife at all ever
why'd you add an ever
[Laughter]